So Donald Trump continues to tweet and to
say more and more about how he is bringing
troops home from [inaudible],
from Syria.
And this has been one of the big defenses
and justifications for what is actually a
completely shortsighted and haphazard decision
to abandon the Kurds in Northern Syria who
were immediately attacked by Kurdish forces
after American troops pulled back.
We're bringing troops.
Home has been the story, except it turns out
that that is also not true.
Trump tweeted that the troops are coming home
and then the Pentagon chief Mark Esper said,
well, they're not really coming home.
They're going from Syria to Iraq.
The troops are actually going to the epicenter
of so called endless war in Iraq.
And when you look at the details of the entire
situation, it is truly in every sense, the
worst of American foreign policy.
And I'll explain what I mean.
Uh, we abandoned the Kurds in Northern Syria.
Okay.
So that is a problem.
We immediately have the narrative that getting
troops out of anywhere at any opportunity
is by default the right thing.
And we should be praising Trump for it despite
all of the both circumstantial questions about
it, foreign policy questions about it, motivational
questions about it, blackmail questions about
it.
I mean, all sorts of questions around Trump's
decision.
Okay, but we're told we are at least going
to get troops out of harm's way.
We're going to get out of an endless commitment
that is all good, even if it has some unintended
consequences like the deaths of Kurds, except
we quietly kept a small number of forces in
Northern Syria anyway, not much publicized.
What are they doing?
Not protecting the curds.
They're protecting oil fields.
Oil fields, case in point, prototypical of
American foreign policy.
Abandoned the curds, protect the oil fields.
Okay, but that's not bad enough.
Then Mark Esper says in the same statement
where he says, a small number of troops are
still there protecting oil fields.
He says, all us troops leaving Syria are going
to Western Iraq.
No one is coming home.
The story is false.
The United States is not leaving the region,
and it's really important to understand the
significance of this.
The entire justification for abandoning the
Kurds, opening the door to the resurgence
of ISIS that we are now dealing with.
As the French prime minister recently told
us, it was all about stopping endless and
indefinite military commitments.
Getting out of the region, taking our troops
out of harm's way.
The troops are moving from Syria to Iraq.
We aren't ending indefinite military commitments.
We aren't taking those troops out of harm's
way.
We're not getting out of the region.
We're not doing any of the things that supposedly
are good about the decision to leave Northern
Syria, and we're actually perpetuating many
of the problems that some claim Trump is solving
by leaving Northern Syria.
We're shifting troops around and we're shifting
troops around in a way that has led to Kurds
being killed.
Two, the pleasure, by the way, of Putin and
urge to one, while not accomplishing any of
the outwardly stated goals.
This is a microcosm of foreign policy under
Donald Trump.
It's a combination of everything Trump says
is actually the opposite with not accomplishing
the stated goals, never properly analyzing
what might actually a motivating factor, and
then in the end we're actually doing the opposite
of what it is that we claim to be doing via
these foreign policy decisions.
Now you know the everything Trump says being
the opposite is not new.
There's many examples of that in the Trump
presidency.
Trump says he's going to drain the swamp.
He has filled the swamp more than any president
in recent history.
Trump says he knows trade and he's going to
do better on trade than anybody else.
People fall for it.
Then he starts a trade war that he can't win
and he absolutely decimates Midwestern farmers
in the United States.
He says he will end conflicts of interest
with his businesses.
He actually has more conflict of interest
than ever.
He's funneling millions of dollars into his
pockets by virtue of being president and those
pockets of his friends and family, he will
be the most transparent president with the
most transparent administration.
No press briefings since.
Is it last March?
I mean, has it been nearly what, seven, eight,
nine months since the last actual press briefing?
And of course, bring the troops home and get
them out of harm's way and get out of an indefinite
conflict and an endless conflict.
Uh, and it's the opposite.
It's we'll send them elsewhere while our allies
who have been helping us to fight ISIS, the
Kurds are getting killed.
If you don't see the tragedy that this foreign
policy and this presidency is, then maybe
you deserve this presidency.
I'm sort of at a loss for how to even sum
it up, but the exact opposite of what we were
told this happening is actually what is happening
on the ground.
And you don't have to go to fake news media
to be told it.
You just read the words of Trump's own Pentagon,
chief Mark Esper.
He's telling you what's going on.